okay so rather than denying the pay gap
exists which is what you did at the
beginning of this conversation shouldn't
you say to women rather than being
agreeable and not asking for a pay rise
go and ask for a pay rise make yourself
disagreeable with your book oh
definitely there's that but i also
didn't deny it existed i denied it
existed because of gender
okay that was a different vibe
so
for me i'm the type of person i like to
learn if there's like an area where i am
ignorant and i'm not going to just be
like oh no like
women should be paid more doesn't matter
blah blah blah but from what he is
saying from a psychological standpoint i
can understand that and he's not
generalizing
all women
but i understand that some women can be
more agreeable and sometimes you don't
want someone that's gonna if you need a
big deal done you're not gonna want
somebody that's agreeable you're gonna
want somebody that's like a little
go-getter
but
it's
it's hard when like those factors aren't
talked about and it's just like people
you know gender gender gender gender
gender
but there
there's other factors that play into
that my question if i was to ask him i
would be i would ask him like well what
happens or what
why if there's women that
aren't as agreeable or just have like
those same characteristic
characteristics
as a male why aren't they
looked at as like okay
if i hired this man or if i hired this
woman they would be able to get the same
job done and i could pay them the same